american troops leave afghanistan and
leave hundreds of americans thousands of
green card holders and tens of thousands
of afghan allies behind the biden white
house pats itself on the back for a job
well done and the taliban take over our
helicopters i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the devastating
news in just one moment first your
reminder that as the american empire
dies it's about time that you diversify
into something that actually has some
lasting value like precious metals you
see it at the pump the grocery store and
construction costs another month of the
highest inflation since 2008 another
month where that paper money you're
carrying around is worth less what is
your plan to protect your savings you
have homeowner's insurance in case of a
fire what insurance do you have in place
of inflation sets in further and pushes
prices even higher even folks at the fed
are now saying that this inflation is
probably not transitory my insurance
plan is gold and silver from birch gold
group if you haven't reached out to
birch gold to diversify your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira do it today
text ben 247 4747 get a free information
kit on protecting your savings with gold
they have an a-plus rating with the
better business bureau countless
five-star reviews thousands of happy
customers talk to them have them help
you safeguard your retirement savings
text ben
247-4747 to claim your free no
obligation information kit on holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account again text my name ben to 47 47
47 to take the first step in protecting
your savings today text my name ben to
47 47 47 to get started today alrighty
so
americans are going to have to decide
whether we wish to be a world power
whether we wish to be the most powerful
country on planet earth whether we wish
our values to be promulgated around the
world or whether we wish to just sink
back in a warm bath eat ourselves to
death and then slit our wrists in our
gluttony that seems to be the choice
being made by the biden administration
that we ought to spend money that has
not yet been created in the trillions of
dollars that we ought to pay ourselves
to do nothing and we ought to pat
ourselves on the back for doing all of
this in the name of equity and social
justice and meanwhile that we ought to
allow other
more up-and-coming countries to fill the
vacuum left by the united states in the
wake of our surrender to world events
that seems to be the plan
which is pretty ugly it's a pretty ugly
plan because here is the thing
empire is is generally not a choice very
often empire is simply a reality of the
world this does not mean the united
states must go around conquering
countries and then taking them over as
colonial assets or anything like that it
just means that when you're a very
powerful country you have a lot of
interest in the world those interests
are frequently challenged and if those
interests are challenged you have to
defend yourself and when you leave a
vacuum somebody else fills that vacuum
so for all the talk about how america
needs to
shirk off its burgeoning empire how
america doesn't have to be an empire how
we need to bring all the troops home how
we need to consolidate at home the
history of world powers demonstrates
that this is not actually an option you
either are aggressive in foreign affairs
in defense of your own propriety and
defense of your own
of your own priorities and your own
values or
that gap is filled by somebody who hates
you who ends up taking those resources
and using them against you that is the
history of world affairs it applies all
the way from the spanish empire through
the english empire certainly through the
through the
american empire applies to the roman
empire as well somebody fills the gap
always always in forever somebody fills
the gap and so
your choice is do you stand up for your
prerogative as the world's leading state
or do you not do you have enough
confidence in your own values that you
stand up for that or do you not are you
so busy worrying about whether our
troops learn about transgenderism and
and genderless bathrooms and whether our
kids learn about critical race theory
that you don't care about world affairs
or that you believe that america's so
evil that it has no place on the world
stage or do you believe that america
still is a repository of phenomenal
values and that the world is done an
enormous good when the united states
fills the gap left by great powers great
powers are not going away gang they're
not china is about to fill that gap in
afghanistan russia is about to fill that
gap in afghanistan iran is about to fill
that gap in the middle east these are
all malevolent powers and they all are
not shy about spreading their power
around
the united states again has a choice we
can do what joe biden wants us to do we
can sink back into that warm bath and we
can eat ourselves into oblivion you can
essentially become the the fat blobs
from wall-e
wandering around in space but our end is
not going to be particularly nice
yeah the cowardice has bloody borders
cowardice and retreat end with your
friends getting killed and that is what
we are watching in afghanistan today
there's a greek myth um there's a king
of thessaly who is called erasicthan
and i apologize if i mispronounce the
name
but this particular king in greek
mythology
he uh he was so greedy that he decided
that he was going to cut down a sacred
forest outside of his of his castle
and he was warned by everybody don't cut
down the sacred forest outside the
castle because that is a repository of
our values if you cut down that sacred
forest then something bad will happen he
cuts down the sacred forest and in
return he is cursed he's cursed with an
unquenchable hunger in his stomach
and no matter what he cannot satiate
himself he must eat he must eat and
become so bad that he impoverishes
himself
by eating and eating and eating he has
to eat all the time he sells his
daughter into slavery for food so that
he can eat and then eventually he runs
out of things to eat and he ends up
beating himself to death he literally
ends up eating himself right that is a i
think an excellent metaphor for what a
large swath of the country would have us
do at this point
that we ought to satiate our own hunger
by eating ourselves by cannibalizing our
own society by cannibalizing our values
and we've cut down the sacred forests of
our values and now the only question is
what is going to satisfy that hunger and
apparently what's going to satisfy that
hunger is
endless social welfare benefits
endless spending endless deficits
destruction of many of the key
institutions that were fundamental to
our society because those were tied to
that sacred forest that we just cut down
and then what inevitably happens to
crumbling empires
they crumble
i mean in the end crumbling empires do
not survive
and again that is not because we opted
to be an empire and then we spread our
domain too far and then because we had
imperial overreach then we had to
regress none of that is none of that is
true
afghanistan is a case in point of that
not being true
we are expending minimal resources to
keep that country stable and to prevent
it from falling into the hands of
terrorist enemies and to the hands of
our geostrategic enemies minimal
resources this was not about imperial
overage
this was purely and simply about an
america that does not have the willpower
to be what it is and recognize what it
is on the world stage it's about an
america that is rightly uncomfortable
with colonialism and imperialism
but is
wrongheaded when it comes to the
realities of the world and that is
somebody always fills the gap and the
people who are filling the gap are some
of the worst people on earth
and which brings us to the actual news
of the day the final american military
pull out from afghanistan we should put
an asterisk by final because the chances
that in the future will have to go back
into afghanistan in order to kill
terrorists in order to rescue american
citizens are quite high
we'll get to that news in just one
moment first let us talk about being an
adult if you're an adult you have to
take care of your business and that
means making sure that the people you're
responsible for are taken care of in
case god forbid something should happen
to you you're walking down the street
suddenly you're mauled by a bear you
need to make sure that your family at
least has the money to pay for your
funeral and also has the money to carry
on without you
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could say 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
it could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the license
experts and policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
super simple first you head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling for
free policy genius never sells your
information to other companies and they
don't add on extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
incredibly important to get it right
okay so as of yesterday last night
you know sometime in the evening
eastern time the last u.s military plane
carrying evacuees out of afghanistan
took off and left afghan airspace
general kenneth mckenzie the commander
of us at centcom said at a press
briefing the biden administration was
still in the process of trying to get
american citizens out of afghanistan
even though the united states no longer
has any presence either diplomatic or
military there
according to the new york times the last
vestiges of the american presence in
afghanistan departed the kabul airport
on monday halting an occupation that
cost more than 170 thousand lives and
ended with a complete takeover of the
country by the adversary the us military
spent two decades fighting american
military leaders had said the united
states would continue evacuation efforts
and fully withdraw no later than august
31st but those efforts were wrapped up a
full day early
just days after an attack on the airport
by is coruscant which is the islamic
state killed killing 13 u.s service
members and as many as 170 civilians in
one of the war's deadliest days so
basically joe biden still had another 12
hours to theoretically get people out
and he was like nope we're out
evacuation flights ended on monday and
the military finished packing everything
it intended to fly out of the airport
onto transport planes before loading the
remaining service members the last air
force c-17 with the callsign moose 85
departed at midnight local time carrying
the final american remaining forces a
u.s military official said
uh it was um a full-scale disaster the
country is now completely in the hands
of the taliban which we'll discuss in
just one moment
everything that could have been botched
here was botched
from the
complete destruction of the afghan
military at the hands of the biden
administration which removed all close
air support and military contractors so
the complete surrender of kabul even
though the taliban apparently offered
according to the washington post control
of kabul to the americans to help broker
some sort of agreement with the interim
government
and even if that hadn't worked to at
least ensure that americans could could
get out the bite administration was like
nope just give us kabul airport and you
guys provide the security and then
apparently on the way out
we uh we allegedly killed an afghan
family
so because joe biden was humiliated by
that terror attack at the abbey gate at
kabul international airport
according to local reports on the ground
the united states fired a drone missile
at what was supposed to be a suicide
bomber and now the report's credible
reports from the new york times are that
actually we didn't hit a suicide bomber
we instead killed
a a person named zamari ahmadi
who apparently had ties to the american
military in the past and killed 10
people seven of them kids
that was on our way out
so it is not clear exactly what happened
there so we're still waiting for the
details to emerge suffice it to say it
is hard to imagine a more blown
withdrawal than this one even if you
think the withdrawal was a good idea
last night
the biden administration did not release
the president
from his uh from his rubber padded room
he is still trapped in the basement
watching madlock and eating oatmeal
you would imagine that after the united
states withdraws from a 20-year
commitment in afghanistan and leaves
behind hundreds if not thousands of
americans
thousands of green card holders hundreds
of thousands maybe of afghan allies who
worked with us and millions of people
who don't wish to live under the
predations of the taliban that after all
of that happened you would imagine the
president of the united states might
make an address wrong you would be last
night joe biden was busy hiding in the
basement
he actually put out a written statement
and then he sent out the head of centcom
and the secretary of state to take the
heat here is the statement put out by
president joe biden
he said quote i want to thank our
commanders and the men and women serving
under them for their execution of the
dangerous retrograde from afghanistan as
scheduled in the early morning hours of
august 31st kabul time with no further
loss of american lives the past 17 days
have seen our troops execute the largest
airlift in u.s history evacuating over
120 000 u.s citizens citizens of our
allies and afghan allies of the united
states they've done it with unmatched
courage professionalism and resolve now
our 20-year military presence in
afghanistan has ended so he's going to
pat himself on the back for all of this
for the 13 zed service members for the
170 dead in that suicide bombing for the
millions of people who are going to be
living under the wonderful taliban
regime for the re
rise of of al qaeda and isis oh that's
good according to joe biden he did a
wonderful job according to joe biden joe
biden is the best president he's ever
seen
biden continues tomorrow afternoon i
will address the american people on my
decision not to extend our presence in
afghanistan beyond august 31st for now i
will report it was the unanimous
recommendation of the joint chiefs and
all of our commanders on the ground to
end our airlift mission as planned
okay first of all if that's true if it
was the unanimous recommendation of all
military members on the ground to leave
americans behind every single person in
that chain of command should be fired
unanimous everybody was like yeah you
know we got a couple hundred more people
who are out there minimum and probably
we should just leave
if that was unanimous
then the cowardice doesn't just
rot from the head down it comes from the
bottom up
their view says joe biden i love these
blaming his military commanders right he
can't just take the hit nuts is military
commander he says their view is that
ending our military mission was the best
way to protect the lives of our troops
and secure the prospects of civilian
departures for those who want to leave
afghanistan in the weeks and months be
ahead which is just nonsensical
and now joe biden is claiming that the
best way to secure
the exit of the afghan allies green card
holders and of the americans who are
stuck in afghanistan is to leave
makes perfect sense i know that when
somebody has been kidnapped the best
strategy for getting the kidnapper to
release them is to completely leave them
alone
never bother them just you know just
leave them alone it'll probably be fine
[Music]
says joe biden in this long statement
again he did not appear on camera last
night because the president is not
sentient the president is not with us
and the president happens to have just
done one of the great immoral acts in
american foreign policy history he says
i've asked the secretary of state of
state to lead the continued coordination
with our international partners to
ensure safe passage for any americans
afghan partners and foreign nationals
who want to leave afghanistan this will
include work to build on the u.n
security council resolution past this
afternoon that sent the clear message of
what the international community expects
the taliban to deliver on moving forward
notably freedom of travel oh man a u.n
security council resolution woo boy
by the way notice that yesterday this
big statement touted by the biden
administration including over 100
countries supposedly
didn't include china or russia calling
on the taliban for freedom of travel the
taliban says joe biden has made
commitments on safe passage and the
world will hold them to their
commitments
what with fluffy with fluffy dolls and
rubber hammers how exactly will we hold
them to their commitments
using what power using what threat the
threat of economic failure they've been
living in caves for the last 20 years
the threat of military power you just
withdrew the most powerful military on
planet earth and destroyed the afghan
military in the process
what's the threat exactly
and diplomacy has been characterized as
the velvet glove around the iron fist
but there's no iron fist it's just a
stupid glove
and that's basically the biden
administration strategy he says it will
include ongoing diplomacy in afghanistan
oh weird because we threw all of our
diplomats and coordination with partners
in the region to reopen the airport
allowing for continued departure for
those who want to leave and delivery of
humanitarian assistance to the people of
afghanistan oh interesting who's going
to be um handing out that humanitarian
assistance would that be the taliban so
basically he's now saying that we are
now going to become the chief financial
sponsors of the taliban that's what he's
saying right there
this is amazing okay then he says we
should be grateful
jeremiah says we should be grateful in
this statement you ready well you know
i'll get to joe biden's statement that
we should all be grateful in a second
that's astonishing we should be grateful
there there are no words to describe the
unmitigated gall
of this human being
first let's talk about something a
little bit lighter
the reality is that you need a great
t-shirt the best t-shirts are all from
cuts i know because pretty much all the
t-shirts i own are from cuts shirts five
years ago cuts founder steve borelli set
out to create clothes for every occasion
the modern man faces since then cuts has
become not only the tesla of t-shirts
but they do hoodies and polos and
sweatshirts and more get ready and stay
ready for any occasion with clothes they
combine classic designs universally
flattering fits
and next level textile technology gq
calls the classic pika pro tri-blend tea
the only shirt worth wearing it is a
pretty great polo shirt i have a couple
of them cuts hoodies feature specially
developed hyperloop french terry fabric
material that's temperature controlled
in ageless or you can try the
wrinkle-free pica polo a design that
keeps you fitted for the office the golf
course or even for your next hot date
cuts is premium with a purpose each
piece is crafted with custom engineered
fabric a comfortable fit without
compromising on timeless universally
flattering style other stuff fits
beautifully it really does this month
marks the cuts 5th anniversary they're
doing it big they've got two collection
drops a product launch and a week-long
special event go to
cutsclothing.com get 25 off site-wide
during their anniversary sale that is 25
off sitewide at
cutsclothing.com go check them out right
now cuz clothing dot com slash man
alrighty back to joe biden's cowardly
ridiculous pusillanimous statement this
is the part that really astonishes me he
says that we should all join him in
grateful prayer
um
prayer for the people you're leaving
behind
prayer for the future of an american
an american nation that seems to be
tottering on the brink
of complete collapse
i mean that is what it feels like not
that the united states is going to
collapse overnight i should say that we
are on the brink of irr irrevocable
decay i think would be a more accurate
way of putting it
what exactly should we should be
grateful for so here's what joe biden
says first for our troops and diplomats
who carried out this mission of mercy in
kabul and at tremendous risk with such
unparalleled results an airlift that
evacuated tens of thousands more people
than any imagined possible really did
any imagine that possible
really is that what happened so you
should be grateful for me right he says
we should be grateful for the for the
service members we're all grateful for
the service members only one of us put
them in direct harm
by isis suicide bombers that would be
you president biden all of us are very
grateful to the service members for the
sacrifices they've made over the last 20
years only you decided to hand over the
country to the people who were killing
our troops for the last 20 years only
you
so i am perfectly grateful for the
people who made the sacrifices that i
did not i am not grateful at all for a
commander-in-chief who is a buffoon and
a fool
and who has made all of those sacrifices
nugatory over the passage of time
but he says we should be grateful when
he says we should we should join him in
grateful prayer he says we should pray
for the troops and diplomats but what he
really means is that we should be
grateful and prayerful to him because of
course he's the one who organized this
massive incredible victorious airlift
second to the network of volunteers and
veterans who helped identify those
needing evacuation guide them to the
airport and provide support along the
way by the way if you talk to the
network of volunteers and veterans they
will say the bite administration was
essentially no help why was it left to a
network of volunteers
and veterans
voluntarily working outside the auspices
of the american government to get people
out why
that's joe biden and third to everyone
who is now and who will welcome our
afghan allies to their new homes around
the world and in the united states you
know what would have been better is if
they could have stayed in afghanistan
you know what that would have required
by the way a presence on the ground of
about 3 000 american troops according to
the joint chiefs of staff
and a continued financial obligation of
less money
than we just handed to the taliban in
terms of military weaponry we apparently
handed about 85 billion dollars in
military weaponry to the taliban we were
spending about 70 billion dollars a year
in afghanistan to simply hold up the
country and then finally says joe biden
i want to end with a moment of gratitude
for the sacrifice of the 13 service
members in afghanistan who gave their
lives last week to save the tens of
thousands and then he lists off all of
the people who were killed in the
suicide bombing that he made possible by
handing security over to the taliban
what unmitigated i mean really the the
utter shamelessness of this president
you should be ashamed you should feel a
deep and abiding shame instead
he is he's sitting at home in his
recliner
thinking about what a wonderful job he
has just done
not only in in
effectuating the decay of america as a
country but also in putting american
troops in harm's way and forcing
volunteers to do the work that he
wouldn't allow the military to do what a
disgrace the president of the united
states is my god
and for all you people out there who are
like well yeah but trump you know trump
didn't do this
whatever problems he had with trump you
know what he didn't do this
okay so the president was apparently too
embarrassed to actually go out and
announce this thing himself so instead
he sends out his lackeys to do it for
him today we are going to get the
president of the united states
wobbling his way through another
lackluster speech i am sure but as of
last night he wasn't going to take any
of the questions so he sends everybody
else to go out and take the hit here is
general kenneth mckenzie of centcom
announcing the completion of the removal
of final troops yesterday
i'm here to announce the completion of
our withdrawal from afghanistan in the
end of the military mission to evacuate
american citizens
third country nationals and vulnerable
afghans
the last c-17 lifted off from hamad
karzai international airport on august
30th this afternoon at 3 29 pm east
coast time and the last manned aircraft
is now clearing the airspace above
afghanistan
okay and then he continued he said this
is the end of our 20-year mission which
is pretty incredible the end of our
20-year mission was handing the entire
country back to the taliban and as you
will see the taliban are having their
day in the sun here is a general kenneth
mckenzie again every single person who's
part of this chain of command should be
ashamed of themselves and should be
fired why is it that nobody gets fired
over this you lose a 20-year war to a
bunch of rag tag
cave dwellers you handed american
military equipment and you're patting
yourselves on the back
tonight's withdrawal signifies both the
end of the military component of the
evacuation but also the end of the
nearly 20-year mission that began in
afghanistan shortly after september 11
2001.
it's a mission that brought osama bin
laden to a just end along with many of
his al-qaeda co-conspirators and it was
not it was not a cheap mission the cost
was 2461 u.s service members and
civilians killed and more than 20 000
who were injured
okay so
how is all that going back in
afghanistan by the way
we'll get to that in just a moment
because suffice it to say that all the
purposes for which we went have now been
completely overthrown remember joe biden
said we only went there for two reasons
one to kill osama bin laden which was
one reason but that was not the biggest
reason
and the second was to stop the threat of
afghanistan being a terror base
afghanistan is now a giant terror base
run by the same exact people who housed
osama bin laden and by the way who have
welcomed back in al qaeda
isis is now extremely active in
afghanistan
and
with the tacit backing of not only the
pakistani isi in many ways but also the
chinese military i'm sure
so things are significantly worse than
they were in 2001 by the way they're
armed with 85 billion dollars of
sophisticated american military
equipment they didn't have that crap in
in just one second we'll get to the
taliban
celebrating wildly because this is the
biden legacy we'll get to that in a
moment first let us talk about your
sleep quality so i will admit i have not
been sleeping well since this all went
down but when i do climb onto my
mattress at night not the one made of
money the other one that is my helix
sleep mattress that's more comfortable
than the mattress made of money it is in
fact priceless the helix sleep mattress
is so good it is made just for me helix
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and for mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to the mattress comes right to
your door ship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix has been
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to helixleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they've got a 10 year warranty you
can try it out for a hundred nights risk
free they'll pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all their
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com
ben that's helixsleep.com for 200 bucks
off and two free pillows already so
meanwhile the taliban proving that they
are back and back with vengeance
so here is some video last night you
could be forgiven if you saw this video
and you thought these were american
military members walking into an
american base they are not these are
members of the taliban who have american
gear they are outfitted in american
uniforms they're wearing american night
vision goggles and they are walking into
an american air base where there are in
fact american helicopters so uh well
done everyone
they are carrying american rifles
they're clad in american in american
uniforms
we're here right now
with the taliban as they enter into the
what was only minutes ago
uh it was an american controlled portion
of the military airport
now they've taken over
and there they are all wearing american
gear
so um they uh they didn't just uh defeat
the americans in their own view and
they're now wearing around their skin so
that is uh that is pretty amazing also
remember there was this talk about their
goat herders they can't fly our
helicopters yeah um uh yesterday they're
they were flying around our helicopters
here's some video from kabul
so apparently they found somebody who
knows how to at least fly a helicopter
glad we gave them a helicopter so you
the law-abiding american citizen you
cannot have an ar-15 but the taliban
will just hand them our helicopters
and uh they're using it to a good effect
the helicopters allegedly
there's video that emerged from kabul
yesterday of them using our helicopters
to excellent effect namely to take their
enemies and tie them to the bottom of
the helicopters and then hang them
scarface style so this this video
emerged yesterday
[Music]
you can see there is a person who is
hanging from the bottom of the
helicopter
[Music]
so uh things are going incredibly well
in taliban land already meanwhile
remember that time that joe biden said
al qaeda wasn't in afghanistan that we
defeated al-qaida in afghanistan so our
purpose there was done oh yeah um one of
the al-qaeda leaders is back in fact
this is one of the co-founders of al
qaeda along with osama bin laden good
friend to osama bin laden he arrives
back in afghanistan to plaudits and
cheers
taliban leaders are back
and al qaeda comes with them
a good thing that we said that we
wouldn't allow any country that harbors
al-qaeda to its regime to survive
i've noticed not only at surviving but
uh they're back and they look exactly
the same as they did 20 years ago so i
hope you enjoyed that
meanwhile women are sitting outside the
kabul airport pleading and speaking
english saying uh where the hell are we
supposed to go now and they have a good
question here's some of that video
emerging yesterday
[Music]
president by then president of the
united states please save us our
families
save us our lives
we don't know what to do there please
help us please help our families we
don't know we are in danger it is many
days that we are outside the hcar and we
didn't get access
what should we do please save us
we should be thankful and grateful guys
we should be praying in in gratitude to
the to the president of the united
states
and by the way um jens hockey was asked
okay so you've said that there's going
to be quote unquote over the horizon
capability here right you said that
we're going to be able to strike at
targets inside afghanistan terror
targets inside afghanistan she was asked
about this yesterday and uh she had no
good answer as to whether we have any
sort of actual over the horizon capacity
is there any concern that we're limited
in our ability to respond in a timely
manner if we've got eight hours of
flight time and then they can only hang
out over the target for like four or
five hours before they've got to turn
around and go back is there a future
sort of ongoing
uh worry that we're going to be behind
the eight ball again
well first i would say the fact that we
have had two successful strikes
confirmed by centcom tells you that our
over the horizon capacity works and is
working oh really because i noticed that
that over the horizon capacity was not
over the horizon that was that we had
people in afghanistan at the time now we
don't
also one of those airstrikes allegedly
killed an entire family so um
yeah
it turns out that the targets that
you're striking are only as good as the
people who are painting the targets
okay but all of this puts aside a rather
large american specific issue forget
about the geopolitical and geostrategic
interests the united states holds here
let's talk for a second about the actual
acute issue
america is now admitting that we left
people behind
that's an unbelievable statement
now jimmy carter became not president
because there were 50 americans who were
taken hostage in iran we have left at
the very least 250 americans under the
tender care of the taliban plus
thousands of green card holders plus
tens of thousands of people who worked
with us
now
this administration's been lying about
this all along
remember it was just a couple of weeks
ago that joe biden said if there are
american citizens left behind we'll get
them out remember he said this to george
stephanopoulos this is like
a week and a half ago
are you committed to making sure that
the troops stay until every american who
wants to be out is out
yes how about our afghan allies does the
commitment hold for them as well
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31 but if we don't
the troops if we don't we'll determine
at the time who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out liar
liar liar
god bleep liar what a liar he is what a
liar remember jen's hockey got very
upset with peter ducey for saying
they're americans stranded in kabul
again it's a week and a half ago i think
it's irresponsible to say americans are
stranded they are not we are committed
to bringing americans who want to come
home home we are in touch with them via
phone via text via email via any way
that we can possibly reach americans to
get them home if they want to return
home there are no americans stranded is
the white house's official position on
what's happening in afghanistan i'm just
calling you out for saying that we are
stranding americans in afghanistan when
i set when we have been very clear that
we are not leaving americans who want to
return home we are going to bring them
home and i think that's important for
the american public to hear and
understand it's important for the
american public to be lied to by jen
saki every single day repeatedly
and then for all of her cheerleaders in
the press to start clapping like seals
so um here was the head of centcom
general mckenzie yesterday saying yeah
we didn't get everybody out
there's a lot of heartbreak associated
with this departure we did not get
everybody out that we wanted to get out
but i think if we stayed another 10 days
louie we wouldn't have gotten everybody
out that we wanted to get out and there
still would have been people who would
have been disappointed with that it's a
it's a tough situation but i want to
emphasize again that simply because
we have left that doesn't mean the
opportunities for both americans that
are in afghanistan that want to leave
and uh and afghans who want to leave
they will not be denied that opportunity
i think our department of state is going
to work that very hard in the days and
weeks oh man the department of state is
going to work it's super hard we'll get
to the department of state in a second
they're going to tickle the hell out of
those taliban members they're gonna hit
them with pillows made of foam
they're gonna send them some strongly
worded statements to those illiterate
cavemen let me just tell you that
what a humiliation i mean really like if
you're general mckenzie at some point
don't you just have to say i'm not going
out there and i'm gonna repeat this
garbage
aren't you gonna say like get somebody
else to be your spokesperson on this
because this is pathetic
is that what yeah man i mean we're
taking out all of the we're taking out
the most powerfully armed military in
the history of the world but let me tell
you ned price and that team over at
state tony blinken he's gonna be
on his phone with those people at the
other end of the phone they're gonna be
picking up an actual rock connected to a
wire like fred flintstone and they're
gonna be talking to him and let me tell
you we're going to exert such
unbelievable leverage
we are going to absolutely threaten not
to open a planned parenthood in kabul
unless they give us back our people
i mean we are going to send them so much
literature about their lack of
opportunity
for lgbtq people in afghanistan
we are going to chide them so hard
we are not going to send them a pride
progress flag unless they let our people
out
our state department will not stand for
any of this sort of stuff
here's general mckenzie explaining oh
you know they're just low hundreds low
hundreds no we don't exactly no but it's
in the low hundreds at least it's not
the high hundreds or the thousands or
something it's the low hundreds
oh the low hundreds you mean like at
least five times as many people as the
iranians had during the hostage crisis
of 79 interesting
the military phase of this operation has
ended the diplomatic sequel to that will
now begin and i believe our department
of state is going to work very hard to
allow any american citizens that are
left and we think the citizens that were
not brought out number in the low very
low hundreds uh i believe that we're
going to work we're going to be able to
get those people out i think we're also
going to negotiate very hard and very
aggressively to get our other afghan
partners out
we're going to go
it's negotiate hard
with john mcclane
so much negotiation
underneath this pillow i have a gun and
underneath this gun i have another
pillow
that that last pillow is the one i'm
going to be using in this negotiation
you removed every capacity we had you
removed all the leverage we had you're
now begging the taliban and by the way
you're gonna bribe them the only
question is whether you're gonna do it
illegally the bind administration is now
claiming as we will see that they are
going to funnel the money through the un
which presumably will make it legal
which by the way we've done before i
mean we fund the unrwa which funds
terror groups all over the uh the
palestinian authority in hamastan so why
not we can do it here too
general mckenzie said you know we
couldn't get everybody out but we did do
a good job given the challenges yes i
mean who created those challenges
what are those challenges i didn't i
wasn't aware there were any challenges i
was told this was smooth it was all part
of the plan
so funny how you mentioned there are
challenges
well would you like to discuss what
those challenges were and how they got
there general mackenzie or would you
prefer to continue kissing the feet of
the people who continue to maintain your
position at the head of centcom
you would like to bring out everybody
that wanted to come out we're not able
to do that situation wouldn't allow it i
think we did a very good job of getting
everybody that we could get that we
could get out given the unique change
the challenges of the tactical situation
on the ground
the fact that really not if not all
americans wanted to leave their
americans that for a variety of reasons
want to stay for a while i think we'll
go back and they'll have the opportunity
to uh they'll have the opportunity to
revisit that and come out if they want
um yeah great also by the way
remember how we left early
we left early not only did we leave
early none of the last jets had
americans on them so for all this talk
about how we were working until the last
minute to get people out we absolutely
were not here's mackenzie saying yep no
we sent some empty jets back
no american citizens came out on the
last what we call the joint tactical
exfiltration the last five jets to leave
uh we we maintained the ability to bring
them in up until immediately before
departure but we were not able to bring
any americans out that activity ended
probably about 12 hours before our exit
although we continued the outreach and
would have been prepared to to bring
them on until the very last minute but
none of them made it to the airport and
were able to be and were able to be
accommodated
so you know no biggie we left early and
we left bunch of people behind and the
last few flights were empty but we did a
great job mackenzie also is playing
defense for the taliban which of course
they have to do if you surrender to a
group of people who obviously are
outclassed by you militarily you have to
have an excuse the excuse from this
administration is that the taliban are
now our friends they're our best friends
now here's general mackenzie
just un unreal talking about how
wonderful the taliban have been
i will tell you the taliban have been
very pregnant very pragmatic and very
business-like as we have approached this
uh withdrawal we did not turn it over to
the taliban uh general donahue one of
the last things he did before leaving
was talk to the taliban commander that
he had been coordinating with as soon as
with about the time we were going to
leave just to let them know that we were
leaving but there was no discussion of
turning anything over
of that at all they they were pragmatic
they were business-like you know really
i was kind of surprised at their
pragmatism in their business-like manner
as they allowed a suicide bomber to kill
a bunch of americans uh and as they
threatened to kill all of our allies and
were dragging people out into the
streets house by house and beating women
it was really pragmatic though i mean
super duper pragmatic
okay in a second we're gonna get to the
state department which again remains
when you talk about the quote unquote
deep state you know career bureaucrats
who continue to design policy despite
being lifelong incompetent the state
department is the repository of all
these nerdy wells it's just a repository
of useless human beings we'll get to the
pathetic state department in just one
second and its head tony blinken who
never should be in charge of anything up
to and including a popsicle stand we'll
get to that in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that if you've
got a medical issue you really do need
to just go get it solved with roman and
get a free online evaluation on ongoing
care for erectile dysfunction all from
the comfort and privacy of your home
roman ready means confidence the
confidence you know you can rise to the
occasion in the moment a u.s licensed
health care professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships you
free with two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward convenient
and discreet getting started is super
simple just go to getroman.com ben
complete an online visit today take care
of your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today connect
with the us licensed healthcare
professional and get the problem taken
care of go to getroman.com today if
you're prescribed get 50 off your first
month of ed treatment make sure you're
ready to have confidence in control this
summer roman ready again you got a
medical problem a lot of people just
wait around hope it goes away that's not
going to happen with ed you really do
need to get it taken care of so you can
do it quickly discreetly and
inexpensively why wouldn't you head on
over to getroman.com ben today if you're
prescribed get 50 off your very first
month of ed treatment that is
getroman.com
ben alrighty well it's never been more
important to understand what's going on
in the political sphere that's why we
started our newest podcast morning wire
the daily morning show is dedicated to
bringing you all the news you need to
know without any spin or hidden agenda
it's the only daily podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to make sure fact based
news still has a platform we need your
help to keep it trending towards number
one so subscribe and start listening now
to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear
there is also the legacy media and then
there's daily wire if you want the news
no other media outlet covers i'm
recommending to you you need to get the
daily wires readers pass if you sign up
today you'll get a free four-week trial
and unlock exclusive access to editorial
content that just doesn't exist anywhere
else after the trial is up our price is
just four bucks a month so that's a
great deal sign up right now for your
readers pass at dailywire.com
subscribe right now and hurry because
our four week free trial deal that that
deal it ends today august 31st you'll
find trending political and cultural
topics penned by everyone from me to
candace owens take for example my latest
piece here's what went wrong in
afghanistan and what we should have done
differently or check out our readers
past collections different series of
articles on a given subject current
collections include the hunter biden
files and blm the organization behind a
movement when you sign up with readers
pass you also get access to the morning
wire newsletter a monday through
saturday email covering the top stories
you need to know available only to daily
wire members all of this can be yours
for just four bucks a month and act fast
to get your free four week trial at
dailywire.com subscribe
it is a good deal it's also never been a
better time to take it because our offer
ends today on august 31st so what
exactly are you waiting for get informed
get your readers passed today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so by the way we didn't just
leave americans behind for those of you
who are in the category of i care about
dogs more than i care about human beings
i'm just going to point out that the us
military abandoned its contracted
working dogs to the taliban which means
they're just going to shoot them the
american humane society condemned the
effective death sentence the us
withdrawal from kabul in favor of the
islamist taliban militia has spelled for
contract working dogs
according to robert ganzard american
humane president and ceo these brave
dogs do the same dangerous life-saving
work as our military working dogs
deserved a far better fate than the ones
which they have been condemned it
sickens us to sit idly by and watch
these brave dogs who valiantly served
our country be put to death or worse
uh the uh mr ganzar said the contract
dogs should have their status upgraded
to prevent such future abandonments well
presumably they won't be abandoned in
the future the same way because um
because biden won't be president forever
but you know just a pathetic capper
meanwhile the state department trotted
out the uh inimitable tony blinken
so blinken
who always has a deer in the headlights
look i mean just consistently he has
never looked not overwhelmed by his job
he continued to look overwhelmed by his
job while taking a victory lap for this
debacle
so he said he wants to commend our
diplomats yes our diplomats did such a
stellar job here what a great job by our
diplomats
many many people made this possible oh
yeah i'm sure that's true i want to
commend our outstanding diplomats
who worked around the clock
and around the world
to coordinate the operation
they volunteered for duty at the kabul
airport
they flew to transit countries to help
process thousands of afghans bound for
the united states
they deployed to ports of entry and
american military bases to welcome
afghans to their new homes
oh man look at those diplomats they've
been doing such a wonderful job in fact
they're doing such a great job that
we're leading with diplomacy while
having no diplomats on the ground this
is the new line by the way this is a
line that you hear so much from people
on the foreign policy left which is why
don't we unleash diplomacy okay
diplomacy is a tool it is not a strategy
okay diplomacy is one of a
many tools in the toolbox when it comes
to foreign policy but it is not a
strategy you hear people and left talk
about diplomacy like it's a strategy
well you know we have our strategy is
get wavered diplomacy
that's that's not a strategy
at all okay that's just the thing that
you can use and if it doesn't work you
better have some other tools in your
toolbox you're willing to use but we
have no other tools that means diplomacy
is the strategy and it's not a strategy
so here is tony blinken saying we're now
going to lead with diplomacy
um yeah that's worked out well so far
a new chapter of america's engagement
with afghanistan has begun
it's one in which we will lead with our
diplomacy
the military mission is over
a new diplomatic mission has begun
oh and it's a new diplomatic mission wow
i'll bet that's gonna go great because
if there's one thing the taliban love
it's diplomacy it's worked out
fabulously in the past the the
diplomatic mission it ended with the
taliban completely eating our lunch and
taking over afghanistan and all of our
military equipment to boot so
probably it's been great
also um lincoln said as an uh let me
just give you an example says tony
blanken of how effective our diplomacy
is we have already put together a super
a super miffed and pissy
diplomatic letter to the taliban i mean
man that letter is pissy
the attitude on that letter let me tell
you
if i read that letter says tony blinken
i would probably like stop for a moment
and i would think about it very
seriously
here's tony blinking talking about this
this incredible
masterful letter the kind of letter that
changes the world
more than half the world's countries
have joined us in insisting that the
taliban let people travel outside
afghanistan freely
as of today
more than 100 countries have said that
they expect the taliban to honor travel
authorizations by our countries
and just a few short hours ago
the united nations security council
passed a resolution that enshrines that
responsibility laying the groundwork to
hold the taliban accountable if they
reneged
so the international chorus on this is
strong
and it will stay strong
amazing wow it's such the international
community so strong that all of nato has
been ripping the united states up and
down the british parliament is screaming
at joe biden and tony blink and put
together a letter with like a hundred
countries that doesn't include china or
russia
but it's super duper important
also you know he says there's a u.n
security council resolution this is from
politico quote a divided u.n security
council pressed the taliban on monday to
live up to its pledges to let people
leave afghanistan after the us withdrew
its forces but
china and russia refused to back the
resolution which they portrayed as
diverting blame for chaos surrounding
the u.s pull-out oh so like he says it
was the u.n security council resolution
and uh and so everyone's on board except
for like the two countries that now have
the biggest stake in afghanistan because
we left
china which is there for the rare earth
minerals and russia which is there to
basically rub america's nose in it so
the two other competitive world powers
with the united states china and russia
are both not interested in whether the
taliban allowed people to leave but tony
blanken says diplomacy is the way
forward
the measure also calls for letting
humanitarian aid flow upholding human
rights and combating terrorism well i
mean if the forces that just left in
ignominious surrender call for upholding
human rights and combating terrorism
then probably that's what's going to
happen
french deputy ambassador nathalie
broadhurst said after the vote quote the
eyes of all afghans are watching this
council and they expect clear support
from the international community
wow wow the international community wow
french president emmanuel macron said
sunday the resolution would propose a
uncontrolled safe zone in kabul for
humanitarian operations but instead the
resolution called for quote all parties
to allow full safe and unhindered access
for aid groups
oh so there won't be a safe zone in
kabul but there will be a call for the
taliban to be nice
probably it's gonna work guys they're
like hanging people from helicopters
already
probably if we guys tony blinken is we
got this man our diplomacy is top-notch
then tony blinken gets really mad he put
on his mr potato head angry eyes and he
says any legitimacy will have to be
earned
from whom you just surrendered
every step we take will be based not on
what a taliban like government says
but what it does to live up to its
commitments
the taliban seeks international
legitimacy and support our message is
any legitimacy and any support
will have to be earned and if you don't
earn it then you won't get it yet
cavemen who can't read but who have our
military equipment and who just
surrendered to
okay then blink and decided you know
what not taking any questions i'm out
he's he makes a statement turns around
just for the exit
who risked or sacrificed their lives
as part of this long mission
right up to today
thanks for listening
that no american would be left behind
yeah um no american will be left behind
everybody will be left behind the bid
administration's back
such courage such unbelievable courage
alrighty meanwhile you can start to see
the media turning in real time from joe
biden is a disaster and this is
horrifying to
probably joe biden was right and you
knew this was coming
right it was only a matter of time so
the coverage from the people on the
grounds in afghanistan who have spent
time there who have dealt with the
american military there who have spent
years there covering the conflict that
coverage was universally negative last
night and the media were fighting mad
about it on all the networks they were
saying you know this is brutal it's
vicious it's terrible it's cowardly and
it is it's all of those things
so take for example take for example
david martin on cbs he said there's no
question we're leaving for political
reasons this is not about military
necessity
this is again david martin from cbs news
reporting from the pentagon
it's on us
and by us
i mean us not not the
800 000
who who fought there they did what they
were told to
but
we in this country
made political choices
that
led to
where we are today
and they may turn out
in history to be the right political
choices
they may turn out to be the wrong
political choices
they might be but they're political yes
they are political choices and they are
the wrong political choices and we can
see it happening in real time nbc's
richard engel who has been very good on
this particular issue right richard
engel's been reporting on the ground in
afghanistan
i was at an event uh at which richard
engel spoke fairly recently like just a
few months ago and he was predicting all
of this he was saying yeah i've gone to
bagram air base and i'm like going
around i'm looking he did a report where
he went and he like looked into empty
air bases there was no one there it had
been basically abandoned the united
states was turning over the whole thing
to the taliban
and engel says yeah we've turned this
country over to the taliban
this was a humbling day for the united
states a day of humility for a world
superpower afghanistan has been called
the graveyard of empires the british
empire fought in afghanistan and
withdrew in defeat the soviet union
occupied afghanistan for 10 years and
withdrew in defeat the united states
fought in afghanistan for 20 years and
is now tonight
withdrawing just completed its
withdrawal in defeat
okay meanwhile abc's ian pennell says
we're abandoning these people on the
ground which of course is true
i think many people will be left
questioning tonight about the way those
decisions were made the way the
evacuation was handled and a final
thought really just to those people
still stuck in afghanistan at home
afraid and feeling abandoned and that of
course is all true but you can see in
real time as the media try to switch the
narrative so for example the new york
times has a piece called quote what
voters in a california swing district
say about afghanistan
so they just went and they interviewed a
bunch of people who agree with joe biden
is basically the story
and the new york times is holding up
california's 39th congressional district
that's the district with hacienda
heights in it they're holding up that
district as a swing district it went
54-44 for joe biden in the last
presidential election so the new york
times found a democrat lean district
and uh and then they found a bunch of
people who agree with joe biden
quote brenda and leo ortiz had paid
enough attention to the news from
afghanistan that it was hardly a
surprise when their 11 year old son
asked them a question how could so many
americans be killed last week miss ortiz
41 tried her best to explain giving
their son a brief history lesson on
osama bin laden the taliban and isis but
by saturday miss ortiz was focused on
more personally pressing matters her
three children were completing their
first month of in-person schooling since
the start of the pandemic she said she
was saddened by the death of americans
but she wondered aloud how she could
possibly focus on a crisis on the other
side of the world when there was more
than enough to worry about in the united
states in her own backyard i don't think
it was ever gonna be easy to leave miss
ortiz said while watching her children
play soccer
at the end of the day our country is
where we need to be focusing we have our
own issues getting the kids to school
healing our communities it's not our war
to fight anymore
at a time of deep partisan division in a
southern california congressional
district where democrats narrowly
outnumber republicans voters interviewed
over the weekend were largely united on
at least one issue after a two-decade
war president biden was right to pull
american troops out of afghanistan well
look to the new york times to
immediately ignore all of the current
polling which shows that this move is
deeply unpopular that joe biden blew it
in massive fashion and instead find
anecdotal evidence that a bunch of
people agree with the decision to pull
out of afghanistan more broadly now
that's not a shock in every poll
americans say they don't want us to be
in afghanistan then when they are asked
how do you feel about having like 2 500
troops in afghanistan just to make sure
the taliban don't take over the country
and so it can hit al-qaeda a majority of
americans support that this is the
problem of polling data polling data
very often depends on exactly what you
are polling if you poll americans on the
broad question of whether we ought to
have troops in far-flung lands americans
will say no if you pull americans on the
exact number of troops the exact cost
and what it is we are seeking to prevent
americans are generally in the ascent
okay that is that is how it works on
everything americans generally when
asked would you like to cut government
services they're like absolutely and
then you say okay would you like to cut
this service and they're like no
this is true throughout polling data so
what the new york times does here is
they just go and they find a couple of
people who agree with joe biden and they
weave it into a front page story
the bombing at kabul airport says the
new york times had done little to change
their minds the killing of 13 soldiers
leaving them more numb than saddened
many said they were simply too
overwhelmed to pay close attention to
another overseas crisis we have a lot of
mending here to do said miss ortiz who
considers herself a political moderate
and voted for mr biden
afghanistan could be ignored say many of
the voters in hacienda heights
but the possibility of they're too young
to be vaccinated children getting sick
could not
again like this demonstrates everything
right okay the reality is that you're
too young to get vaccinated children are
not getting particularly sick from kovid
the new york times is pushing that
narrative
leaders in washington might worry about
the threat of terrorism or america
standing with allies but voters in
hacienda heights said they were far more
concerned about issues directly
affecting them coven 19 homelessness and
climate change to name a few who wrote
this the new york times wrote this
climate change so i'm not worried about
what just happened in afghanistan where
america completely humiliated itself and
handed over an entire country to
america's worst enemies
i'm really worried about climate change
says the mom from hacienda heights
climates change
if you said cover 19 in homelessness i
might go along with you in l.a climate
change seriously
they seemed hesitant to hold biden
accountable for last week's attacks at
least for now when you have no good
choice you still have to pick one said
patrick huang a 65 year old independent
who has voted for both republicans and
democrats
so um i would love to see a quote from
someone in this article
who uh who
was like
actually divided about this decision
instead they found somebody who voted
for trump named tanya chang and andrew
chang in downtown fullerton saying they
may be exited more quickly than they
should have but i think it was right to
be out it was multiple presidents
missteps we couldn't have stayed there
forever
even representative young kim was less
critical of the president than many
lawmakers in her party she said we don't
have the luxury to be sad about what is
happening but we have to resolve gather
information and get people to safety
this is not the time to point fingers
when people are desperate and people are
dying
but she added she was hearing from her
constituents who are not satisfied with
what they're seeing and hearing from our
commander-in-chief
they come in they they quote one person
who's a national trump voter here who
said quote about biden he left americans
behind it's two-thirds of the way down
in the article of course he left how
many people there he led them to become
sacrifices he is old he allowed young
people to die the only thing that makes
me optimistic is that trump is willing
to fight back
so um
this is their entire so watch this will
be the narrative the narrative this is
what biden is hoping for he's hoping
that everybody just forgets about the
250 people they admit are stuck on the
ground in afghanistan who are american
citizens
they're hoping that the foreign policy
reporters who were stationed in
afghanistan get less and less air time
than richard angle goes to reporting
somewhere else and that ian pannell goes
reporting somewhere else
and then all of them just sort of recede
into the background and then we go back
to talking about joe biden's big
spending plans and then we go back to
talking about the insanity of masking
your children but you should very much
mask your children and then we talk
about climate change
they want a change of topic and the
media are going to grant it to them
right now that the american troops are
out this is why biden accelerated the
timeline by the way remember we still
had 12 hours to get people out
he didn't take it biden wanted out now
not because that was the best policy but
because he wanted the headlines to stop
and his assumption is the headlines will
now stop because
getting these people out watch the
language is going to change over the
next 24 hours getting these people out
will now be a protracted process or
negotiating with the taliban or figuring
out ways to get them out and don't you
worry even though it's taking a long
time it'll be okay i mean after all the
international community is using the
power of hashtag they're using the power
of diplomacy to get these people out
they're hoping that you get bored and
you get tired and you get sleepy and by
the way they may be right
they may be right because after all
isn't that the story of what just
happened in afghanistan we got bored and
tired and sleepy and three quarters of
the arguments made about afghanistan are
completely unrelated to the actual
figures on the ground right now and when
you talk to people about afghanistan as
this withdrawal began
people were like yeah we got an endly
endless one you're like yeah there are 2
500 troops there and zero people have
died since february of last year and
like well yeah but but but it's still an
endless war you're like yeah but it's
not
okay but but everybody is still because
the american attention span is five
seconds long
this is how
empires crumble it's how countries
crumble frankly and america right now is
so bored and so fat and so stupid
that we have decided that it is not
important to stand up for foreign
interests we don't have to have any
long-term
vision at all we don't have to think
beyond the next five minutes which is
why we can spend money that our
grandchildren will not be able to repay
it's why we can blow out inflation and
then assume the government is somehow
going to magically take care of it it's
why we can take coveted policies that
are designed to have short-term impact
but serious long-term ramifications and
then champion those
right all of this is dependent on
americans having an attention span that
is
that is shorter than the average looney
tunes cartoon
and dependence on a media that is
willing to lie in favor of democrats and
move on from a news cycle as soon as
that news cycle is no longer important
to them
okay we'll see if it works
we'll see if it works
uh as a cynic i i think it probably will
which is why i think that
for all the talk about joe biden being a
disgrace which he is and pathetic which
he is for all the talk about the
cowardice and the betrayal here and
there's plenty of both
i think joe biden knows that everybody
will just move on and that was his plan
all along if we have to leave americans
we'll leave americans if we have to
leave allies we'll leave allies if we
have to leave green card holders we'll
leave green card holders so long as six
weeks from now we're not talking about
this joe biden does not give a damn he's
checking his watch gang it's all he
cares about he's checking that watch
because every second that ticks by is a
second until we stop talking about this
he knows it
that's why he's checking his watch
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show